foreign
[Music]
hey guys uh I will be in Columbus Ohio
Cincinnati Ohio Boise Salt Lake Utah
Tucson Pueblo Colorado Colorado Springs
Pueblo Colorado for some reason
Charlotte Knoxville Little Rock Arkansas
Nashville Tennessee Calgary Edmonton
Ottawa Montreal Hamilton Ontario
Cleveland Ohio Detroit Orlando Fort
Myers uh that's where I will be get your
tickets at christalia.com for the Don't
Push Me Tour
um and that's that I'm adding more dates
I know you guys are uh always like well
why aren't you coming here it doesn't
matter where I got where I post you guys
are always like well I didn't come here
first of all I've been there probably or
I'm coming I just haven't announced it
yet but thank you uh for coming out and
those are the tickets krista.com
uh so without further Ado this is the
new episode of congratulations
[Music]
my hair is looking fancy man see that's
the thing you know I never know I washed
my hair
and then sometimes
that day it's banging and then sometimes
it's not it's the next day that's
banging and I wash my hair today and
it's banging and I wash my hair every
three four days and that's what's up
dude everyone says I look greasy and
it's all good my babies I look greasy
but I'm not greasy man I'll tell you
what I'm probably one of the cleanest
dudes you know when it comes to uh you
know smells and all that stuff I brush
my teeth all the time shower all the
time the only thing I don't do every day
is wash here because I heard it's bad
for it but I don't really know if I
subscribed to all that maybe it's bad
too uh wash your hair every day but
people are like you gotta leave the
group the grease on it because you know
it's healthy for the hair it's not
healthy to to always wash it it dries it
out I do what I want when it comes to
that kind of stuff and what I want to do
is be clean but you know
sometimes I feel I don't know
and my hair is looking good
and uh and that's that about the hair
stuff really the hair the hair stuff
really is that's what's up I um well I
mean I had a crazy great week
um which is you know
the uh
what should I talk about first I had
well let's just talk about the baby I
mean we had a baby and congratulations
to me and my wife and Calvin and all of
the family members and extended family
and and you know what dude we got
another uh baby in The Log Cabin that's
uh that's gonna help build it uh his
name is William McHenry Dalia and uh he
is beautiful and he's very healthy and
he's strong too uh he rolled over it's
been five days and he already rolled
over that's not common they say like it
takes like a few months and William goes
like this no
uh-uh
um and rolled over in five days so
that's great uh I I I
it's I it's so wild becoming a dad again
uh people say that like oh
congratulations you're a dad again which
is weird to me because you're still a
dad you're you're you've been a dad
you're not a dad again you're a double a
double dad now and um
so it's a it's it's you know we're in
that post partum thing where it's been
six days and
you know I don't know how to even I'm
reminded of all this feeling which is
wild because you know William hasn't
really opened up his eyes yet I mean he
kind of opens up and looks every now and
then but then he's like I liked it
better on the inside you know he's like
one of those convicts that's like I I've
been away for so long I don't know how
to do this anymore I
I'm back in and then just Robs a Bank
not even to get the money just to get
back in there but you can't go back into
the womb
it's destroyed at this point you know so
um
well we don't know if we're going to
call him William or Billy or will or or
Willie Billy boy we're calling him a lot
you know he's a little little boy but
the only comment when he gets to be
older but I like the one of the reasons
why I like William first of all is my
dad's name and second of all it's the
kind of name where you got a lot of
nicknames you can pick you know
chileam
chili chili boy you know Trillium which
is cool when it gets older what up
Trillium
you know
Willie my Nelly probably shouldn't say
that but you know it's
it is it is uh he could pick and we can
pick too so we don't know what we're
gonna call him but William is his name
and uh it's great and it's really
fantastic and we went in to uh first of
all my wife at the end there her brain
it was like it was filled with
just you name it uh what is it the silly
putty she was just so what you know who
she was like the right harm I'm his
right I miss her Sterling everything I'm
his right arm hand man I'm a silly
rabbit is that what he calls you no
that was what my wife was by the end of
it
I would be like would you like a
sandwich and she'd be like let's say
what is it what is that uh well there's
turkey in it no what's a sandwich dude
it was insane
there has been a scrape on our car
her car
it's annoying
and you know because look I'm not
women's great cars and um you know and
it's not because they're they don't know
how to drive that is that is a fallacy
when people say this is a sexist Trope
going around like oh women can't drive I
don't subscribe to that women
they don't care
see I'm not gonna be like oh yeah women
can't drive that's not true it's women
they don't care about your possessions
right so when there's a curb they go
like this oh you know what I'll try that
one
and then you go what you scrape the rip
and they and they say well don't yell at
me and then you feel bad yes dude they
got it all figured out right
but um yeah and so so so so so that's so
we had to scrape on the side of the car
and it's from of all things
our own gate
all right all right so not something
that she
doesn't know about because you know why
dude because it's
our own gate right and it's always there
okay
so she scrapes it
she doesn't just scrape it once she
scrapes it twice here's the great here's
the best thing about it same exact place
you not even two scrapes so I'm like wow
that's amazing how do you even do that
so she's scraping it this is months ago
and I and I I walk out and say babe you
scrape the side of the thing
and she was like I don't know I see it's
because you parked too close and already
I'm just like oh stop the cap okay
you got plenty of feet
on the other side so let's use it
um and she does she doesn't want to get
close to the bloody guts I get it she
doesn't want to scrape the bloody guts
so she'd rather scrape the gear it's
better scrape one card and two cars
that's fine right one time my uncle
backed up my dad's car into his other
car and it's all good you know you gotta
take two of the cars in but so
scrape that I saw it with my own eyes
somehow it's my fault so I say oh you
know
you know what okay fine
I got mad but I tried to swallow it you
know it's real hard to swallow my anger
because you can still tell I'm mad you
know like guys try to like be like well
if I don't react I talk about this in my
ACT but like if I don't react then she
can't get mad at me for not being mad
and then look at you and you're like
this
darting your head around like a like a
like a meerkat
and you're like what I did I didn't say
anything
and there's just a scrape in the car
that would have never happened if I were
driving that is fine
are you saying women can't drive no
that's sexist I'm saying they don't give
a [__] about your possess your
possessions right
that's why there's a [__] banana peel
and then inside of the [__] thing and
it's this is there right
and so but it's fine whatever I realize
life's about bigger issues who cares to
scraping a door my wife's a beautiful
angel who cares right
she texts me the day before we go in to
get
the baby out whatever they call it
inducing induction like like it's like a
Hall of Fame
like we're like the baby's getting
induced women I'm going to get I'm going
in to get induced like they like they
like they caught some fly balls you know
I'm going in to get induced like you're
a member of the 40 40 club
like not dude all right oh hey are you
my wife or are you Ricky Henderson dude
we're going to get induced no dude don't
act like it you you don't act like we're
going to Cooperstown dude
they voted they're they're voted they
want to retire my they want to retire my
shirt which is basically your shirt
because that's all I've been wearing for
the past four months
foreign
I'm going to get induced so we go
and we and and the day before we get
induced she's at Sweet greens and she
texts me she's like you know that valet
that guy that doesn't like me
[Laughter]
up in her head you know hey you know
that valet guy women will say some [__]
where you gotta go like huh well
hold on let me go way back into my
catalog and see if I've ever had a
conversation about this and then you go
and then you say no I I don't know and
then they what what do you mean and then
you're like well okay I don't see how
this is going to work out anything at
all favorable for me
or you can just be like oh yeah that guy
and then they keep talking but then
maybe you'll get caught in a lie so
really there's no win right so
you know the valet guy that hates me and
I I go deep I'm like I'm on like dial up
trying to remember this dude
and I remember the dude I'm like oh yeah
that's right you said he was rude and
the thing and
so I said what's up she was like don't
don't get mad but
I think he scraped the car the Audi and
I am and I say
oh my God no way
and I'm pissed right
I mean I'm I'm pissed but I'm like you
know what
before I get mad let me find out more
information about this
so say where is it and she says on the
door and I said well is it below the
door because if it's below the door then
the good thing is we have to replace
that anyway because of and I'm trying to
be very careful but the [__] that
you did right now I'm not trying to be a
dick but right because of the way you've
been driving Ray Charles right now I'm
not trying to be a dick do you know what
I'm talking about but just the way you
pull in the driveway Helen Keller is an
absolute travesty okay it's like you
might as well have Stephen Hawking
behind the wheel okay
oh no
I scraped the side even he would be
aware of it no you're right I had much
more room next to the bloody gods
I should have pulled more to the right
there were five feet
there were there was five there was so
much negative space and I instead went
left and cut it so close to the gate
that the screw sticking out absolutely
obliterated under the door at the Audi
rsq8
the car is so expensive this will be so
much money
it's going to be so much money and also
it it will be a challenge because would
you have to would you rather fix it
yourself or pay the extremely eye
deductible on this absolute sports
luxury car yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah
your [__] husband and also don't be
mad
commence water coming out commence eyes
raining
um
why are you being so mad it's making my
eyes rain so um
dude I won't do it once I'll do it twice
um anyway dude
so
I say all right well where is she's like
it's on the door and I was like well
send a pic she sends a pic and to me
it doesn't just look like it's near it
it looks like it's exactly on it
it looks like it's exactly on the scrape
oh
well lucky us
so I say babe that looks like the scrape
that you did when you hit the gate and
she says
no I don't know I don't think so and I
said
well you scrape the gate
right in the same place it just says
this one's higher so I say okay you know
what I Choose You know what I choose
happiness
okay now I'm pissed but I choose
happiness because you know what you can
do that
you can do that when somebody goes hey
buddy [__] you you could just go like
this no I choose happiness
so that's what I'm doing
I'll wait for her to get home
no you know what I do I stop at the nail
place that she's at because I know she's
there and I want to go surprise her
and I also and this wasn't a secret
thing but I also do want to I do want to
see this scrape
I pull over I go into the nail place I
say hey what's up and she's like oh
what's up I'm finishing hi oh my God hey
you know so I say oh I'm gonna go I'm
gonna actually go look at this scrape
she says okay I go I look at the scrape
there's one
it's the same exact it's the same exact
scrape as the one that she did
they didn't do it again dude it's her
it's she did it the whole time it was
like the end of The Sixth Sense you're
like oh my God it's you
it was like an M Night Shyamalan movie
at the end where it's just like it was
it was
hard
that's creepy tell me more about that so
now I'm like oh
oh I'll go back and say this is what you
did and she said
it is and I said yeah remember
use memory
and I know that memory is like you know
you don't remember the things that you
don't need to remember but hey check
this out
now
ding ding
something you need to remember that was
the dumbest one I ever did dude
but dude hey check dude oh [__] it's
something she needs to remember
and I'm like babe
you did this she said I did I said yeah
don't you remember and then the thing
and then we got into like a little bit
of a thing and she said I don't know I
didn't really look oh the disrespect
dude
she didn't look she didn't know the
scrape's been there for months and now
she's getting mad at a guy at the
[__] ballet guys live in him and I'm
pissed off at I gotta be I'm like maybe
I have to fight this guy if she said I
think he keyed it
so I'm like we can get this baby out of
you dude because you don't what's you've
got a potato in your head
huh
she's like sorry I don't even know I'm
just pregnant it was like so weird so
oh then that night
I'm on a meeting of a meeting with my
for my
a brain for my addiction you know I'm on
a zoom [__] Anonymous meeting
because I'm a you know because of me and
she knocks on the thing and now I'm like
I'm in a [__] I can't all right I did
she knocks again I open up and I'm so
what's up she said we're going to get
the baby out tomorrow they have an
opening and I was like oh [__] awesome
it's like [__] waiting in line to buy
a Porsche you know they're like it's
here finally
uh we just go in tomorrow and get this
baby so we go in we get the baby out
and uh
man
first of the first time I I we had a kid
it was so emotional for me so I'm like
dude it's gonna be so emotional and I
know that because I think that
that
it's not gonna be as emotional as it was
because I'm ready like because I wasn't
ready last time
this time
he ready right
so
they say you know we get there at 10 pm
they they start they give her like a
pill in the in it in her like it you
know they just literally like go in and
drop it off like it's a prescription
like they go in they drop it off like
it's some film in 1995. they go like hi
I'm the Midwife uh we're gonna start
with
I had no idea but like I know about uh
the balloon thing that they put in women
to make the space for the cervix to
dilate I'm a doctor dude and uh they
pump it up you know
Pump It Up
Joe Budden comes in and he's just like
and so
so before this
because Calvin when he was born it took
14 hours 13 hours but like she was only
in hardcore labor or whatever they call
it I'm a doctor but for like an hour and
a half and that's super quick especially
for the first baby and they're like the
second one comes quicker and I'm like
quicker than an hour and a half I was
like ordering dominoes
so
they're like so all right you're not
really dilating yet your cervix is a
little bit soft
and but so what we're gonna do before we
put the balloon in because the Calvin
just got the balloon they just put the
balloon in [__]
pump it up and now this time they're
like we're gonna drop a pill in there
and I was like what and we're gonna
we're gonna the the doctor looked at the
Midwife looked at me and she was like so
what we're going to do is we're going to
drop a pill in your wife's [__] it's
gonna dissolve it's gonna get a little
bit more softer and then we're gonna put
in the balloon and we're gonna have Joe
Biden come in and I'm like okay right
medical terms we're going to get the
pill we have we have a pill we put it in
your wife's [__] and then what happens
is it dissolves right so we put in our
nappy dog out it dissolves right so your
wife right we open it up we look at the
hatchet wound we put it in the hatchet
wound
um right so what we do is we take this
so there's look there's a hungry fried
butterfly right there's a hungry fry
butterfly so we give this pill to the
hungry butterfly
and um and we put and and they put the
pill in by the way
like birth
it's so complicated
like I know it's completely natural and
at the end of the day that baby's coming
out
and you know back in could you imagine
having a baby back in like the 1500s
that's why so the birth rates were like
the pack the fact that these babies
survived that I'll tell you what man I'm
I was born in 1980. if I was born in I
mean any earlier than that
yo Dead on Arrival
straight up
me
I don't no way no way because there's
got to be that point where you're you
know you're sucking on the inlet
umbilical cord [__] with your tummy
right and then you pop out and by the
time you pop out you're breathing air
you're like all right well what's up
with this but I would have been like I'm
not I don't want to I don't want to
right like I'm sure they had some
high-tech [__] in the 80s where they
were just like we gotta he's coming we
gotta get him out push push they knew
[__] but dude you put me and I'm telling
you anywhere from 1945 earlier I'm not
they don't know enough to get me to come
out dude they don't know enough
so I'm like I'm staying in and I'm
getting to that point where you know
it's like oh he's got to breathe air now
but like I'm scrunched up against the
upper vagina part and I'm like I'm not
coming out and that's me DOA dude
cause I'm smooshed up against the upper
vagina part
I can't breathe you know what I'm saying
but they knew what to do and so they
were like all right do the who who
to my mom so I came out but I'm just
saying dude it's so complicated
it makes setting up like a [__] PS5
look like eating a banana
birth is crazy and that you know it has
to be that way so now there's you know
there's too many people in the world but
this is why because they figured all
this [__] out
and so
so now they're like I'm and so they're
like so the pill dissolved and the
cervix is very we're at two centimeters
so now what we're gonna do we're gonna
put the balloon in and I'm gonna just
check that and there we go and I'm
feeling the head and the wind wife is
like dude there's so much [__] going on
it's like I don't even understand we
gotta move it we're gonna move it so
what happens is the cord is uh might be
below the head and that's bad because
the baby's adjusting the heart rate
might drop but and I'm just like just
this is so she's like and then the Wi-Fi
went out and and so the Wi-Fi is out in
the womb you don't understand what's
happening and it's so much and you're
like I don't want to know any of this
and they're just telling you because
they have to and in a way it kind of
makes you feel better but then
five hours go by and they're like you're
at five centimeters
and they say
check on you in a little bit they leave
my wife's chilling looking at her phone
and all of a sudden she says oh my God
like a [__] like an old lady that has
just seen the most brilliant
the most brilliant
uh what do they call him bougainvilleas
just the most brilliant Bougainvillea
she's ever seen in her life like a 72
year old that just walked by and just
went oh my God like that's how she
looked at me yes dude
[__] naming something different you
know bougain Vegas most [__] name for a
[__] flower
and uh like the book in V is like some
an island you would go to if you were
like
some [__] stupid white idiot chick on
Instagram that has Wanderlust in her
[__] bio you know Wanderlust you know
what Wanderlust means for real hooker
that's what that means I swear to God if
you see a chick bragging about she's
into Wanderlust that means she's sucking
dick on all of the islands
Wanderlust means hooker so
[__] gay speaks the truth man I swear to
God
so
she says oh my God like a 72 year old
seeing a bunch of brilliant
bougainvilleas
and then
I say what and she doesn't say anything
and I'm like you got to follow that up
immediately
during now
or I'm like oh you're looking at online
like what's happening like on all sorts
of red flags are going so
she says I think my water broke and I
say really and I look dude the nurse
comes in peels back the thing it was
like
it was like you know in the movies when
you see water break and you're like okay
well you're like that's not how it is
that probably just leaks a little looks
like the girl's ttn you know
right like you're watching a Julia
Roberts movie and the side character
like their water breaks and it's and
you're like whoa
bro
so much water came out
that it was like
oh how do I say this
harrowing
you know like I was like oh my God I I
had the same feeling I saw on the
opening scene of Saving Private Ryan
when the guy's looking for his arm
because the Germans blew it off you know
and theirs was like oh okay and she and
then Chris was like does that happen
which is the number one thing I say is
this the normal you know you want to
know and she was like does that happen
and the nurse was like yeah and I was
like it doesn't happen
the way she's saying it though you know
say it with more conviction nurse
does that happen uh yeah it can oh but
she's duh she's lying the way she did it
don't sing it yeah but
I'm lying
so now I'm like oh for [__] sake
so the baby's heart rate went down a
little bit because all of a sudden the
baby was chilling on this sack of water
like a bean bag just chilling love is
good you know and then all of a sudden
and the and the babies
uh
what's up
this it was five
all of a sudden Kristen is like man you
gotta put the epidural kick it up a
notch and she starts Contracting the
card
they were like
don't have the baby yet the doctor's not
here this is happening so quickly we're
gonna call the doctor and Chris is like
is the doctor close and she's like yeah
and
so she's having the the the
contractions and the the Midwife is like
just hold it the doctor's not here yet
and Chris is like I can't I gotta push
and then
the doctor shows up
and Kristen's like I can't believe how
this is so she's trying to get her feet
you know the epidural makes your they
stick a syringe in your
back in your
uh spine and then your legs go numb
which is just like nah
that's creepy tell me more about that so
so
she the doctor shows up and the doctor's
like okay let me look and she's like
okay let's have this baby
um so okay so push Kristen pushed once
and William was just like sup
dude he came out
and just she pushed one time
and then we and then the baby was there
and then the baby was so
I mean so
so purple
that I thought it was a California
raisin and I couldn't it was and he came
out and they were like he wasn't really
crying and of course I was scared of
[__]
they're like we got to get him to cry
more hold on and they're like tickling
him and it took like 40 minutes for him
to really just let out that
yeah and then uh well that sounded so
good and so and then um
and now he's great he's so good he's so
healthy and it's just a beautiful thing
and then after the baby came her legs
went numb so that's cool
um
and now her brain [__] works again
thank God
so now I'm a full [__] Family Guy
like forget it
and I'm still not wanting to go to
Coachella so that's great I don't
man it just I know I've always been
against Coachella you know that I don't
always say I'm against it I would just
never go somebody said to me the other
day like would you go to Coachella
ever and I I was like [__] no that seems
like my nightmare I would rather go to
Stagecoach than Coachella that's how
much I don't want to go to Coachella
because I also I'm not like a huge fan
of country but like I would rather go to
Stagecoach because it seems a little bit
more chill like I don't want to be
listening to like hardcore like holy
[__] music I want to be chilled out if
I'm going to be at a [__] place I
want to be chilled out right and you
could probably do that at country
because there's a lot of slow singing in
country you know I know there's Frank
Ocean and [__] but it's like a Coachella
but I just I don't want to go so
uh and then I'm looking at these um
pictures of Coachella
and
I see all the hot chicks and I'm like
I'm gonna
okay I don't wanna okay let's not but no
you know what I mean and then uh I'm
like okay well actually no okay I'm
happy actually
and uh
and I'm like
what would it take for me to go to
Coachella I think
it's just bad
period
also I'm 43 right or do four yeah 40
they still go though
people [__] Live It Up in Coachella
they were so mad like rioting because of
what's his name didn't have the merch
Franco Ocean Frank Ocean wow so Mexican
um
hey you like that guy Frank Ocean right
when he drives around in his Chevy
um
so uh
I don't really know anything about
Coachella to be brutally honest with you
guys
did anything interesting happen
no right same [__] we're in the
Holograms
uh
this whole thing I I looked at
and this was nuts
so let me read this with you
I mean
the whole thing here is insane
parody Hitman
so wait this is a parody Hitman website
that exists
and there is a National Air National
Guardsman that that thought it was real
and allegedly applied for murder For
Hire Jobs first of all don't do that
blindly okay
hey dude uh I am a Hitman I'm out of
work this sucks I'm gonna go on
Craigslist that's basically what he said
okay
Hitman will take care of somebody for
100 flowers
um so this guy Josiah Hosea Jose how do
you pronounce that Ernesto Garcia okay
uh eventually agreed to kill someone for
five thousand dollars on a conversation
with an undercover FBI agent so all
right this is an FBI agent that's
undercover and it's also a parody so
what's the deal here kind of weird don't
really understand it but as we keep
going
Air National Guardsmen was arrested and
charged Thursday with applying to be a
Hitman on a parody website
21 Tennessee came across
www.rentahitman.com
you know
as he was searching for contract
mercenary jobs
to support his family okay made me kind
of pulled up my heartstrings right there
uh the U.S so uh the website was created
in 2005 and to advertise a cyber
security startup but when it failed it
would get inquiries for Hitman services
okay
so it's administrator converted it to a
parity site
with false testimonials from people who
claim to have used its services the
criminal complaint says
wow
wow Garcia applied on the website for
work as a Hitman in February submitting
identification documents and a resume
this guy couldn't just say it was a joke
right
as well as indicating he was an expert
Marksman
earning him the nickname Reaper
um and was employed
in the Air National Guard since 2021
okay Garcia continue to follow up the
website for about a month how stupid can
you be even more identifying information
including his home address and a
headshot dude
a headshot like it's a State Farm
commercial
and eventually agreed to kill someone
for five thousand dollars in a convert
in a conversation with an article so
he met he met up with the guy undercover
agent now when did they get the
undercover agent involved is what I'm
saying
because
this whole thing with Wow and they had a
Target packet with the fictional
individual like this is the guy no
questions
after agreeing to the terms of the
murder Arrangement dude how far was this
joke gonna go
I killed him psych jokes on you no he's
dead though
uh Garcia asked the agent if he needed
to provide a photograph of the dead body
Garcia was then arrested by FBI agents
wow
bro he's gonna get off because he's just
gonna be like nah it's joking I just
want to see how long man this is
hilarious dude for YouTube man it's
gonna be for YouTube My First YouTube
um hey
Josiah
Outsource it
um
a headshot you know
no pun intended
so here's my head shot under special
guilds it says uh beatboxing and I know
you want me to kill a guy but check this
out
dude when beat boxers do that part I'm
out I'm out I can't do it but when
they're like
that part's cool or that
that part but when they go oh
um
you know no music does that um
[Laughter]
when they hit that [__] it's always some
[__] it's always always when you're
in [__] when you're in elementary
school it's always somebody one of the
older kids and he's got bad breath and
[__] just and you're like oh God damn
that smells plastic
wow quadir yeah he does it well but my
God don't get close to him when he does
it
tasting
[Music]
um
if your mother only knew just a beef
jerky um
wow man
wow
oh [__] man
dude everyone's such a [__] [__] in
this life for anyone to judge anyone is
insane dude and this guy's just trying
to you're trying to rent a Hitman rent
dude
remember to return me
ah here we go
oh man
lawyer
what are you
hold on dude
[Laughter]
the lawyer said it
the lie and somebody said
nah a lawyer in that
YSL trial really told the judge
he captain
hold on I will start by saying
that this assertion that
oh [__] cut out
what is his YSL trial
oh Young Thug okay
oh yeah right he he got arrested or
whatever
they say Thug is going to get thrown
under the jail
come on man come on where's the [__]
Wi-Fi
dude black Twitter is hilarious start by
saying
that this assertion that
come on dude
oh man I want to see this so bad yo in
the meantime leave a comment about how
shitty the [__] Wi-Fi is and we have
to fix it so like And subscribe though
and yeah I'll be in Nashville but anyway
dude why won't this [__] go dude and
I'm on the good one too I'm on oh dude
yes it's not working right when I wanted
to [__] literally ruin the whole bit
yeah yes dude a hundred percent ruining
the bid it's still color Wheeling Yes
Man
oh dude come on work
oh my god dude it's 2023 you know that
whole thing that Louis CK said oh be
happy you're in an airplane the Wi-Fi
doesn't work you're 30 000 feet in the
air this is unbelievable you live in an
awesome dude no don't have this [__]
until it works my Wi-Fi should be
working but it's not and if I were to
say my wife I'm working that's captain
why would it not be working right now
okay I'll go into [__] then you know
what I'll go into Safari because I
usually use Chrome if I'm brutally
honest
and I'm gonna use Safari thanks for
sticking with me guys and during these
hard times
I'm pausing it on Chrome and I'm going
sitting on chrome and I'm going into the
here we go here we go into the [__]
uh what is it Safari surfing Safari yeah
oh and it's not even going it's not even
starting on Safari
yeah I have an update I honestly haven't
updated my computer in so long I think I
have [__] birdie which is like one of
the first ones they're on like white
snow leopard now and I got I literally
have [__] beetle
wow dude there's a little apple humor
for you you know what I'll tell you this
much how about the guy oh
dude please work
oh [__] yeah dude it's not working come
on
I will start by saying I I like already
by the way I I'm starting it over just
to at least the the how
you you can tell how
he's trying to you could tell he's
trying to sound smart you can tell this
guy also has a voice with his friends
that's the best and that's as racist as
we get in this podcast I will start by
saying
that this assertion that I did not
mention the 403 argument don't worry
about that okay because it wouldn't be
it I'd have to do it anyway so okay
don't even worry about that okay okay I
understand that it's just not true it's
cap to be honest but um that aside
though
my god dude
this stenographer just like this
Capital was in capital letters
I will start the way he's trying to
suppress his you know I'm saying um I so
check it out so all right so look
I agree we have all come here today you
know by saying that so many assertion
that so I did not mention the 403
argument don't worry about that first
time you ever said the word assertion
I'd have to do it anyway so okay don't
even worry about that okay okay I
understand that it's just not true it's
cap to be honest but um dude
he says it's not true first and then
says it's cap
the other way
you know it's just not true so let's is
Cap to be honest judge uh your honor um
dude
I I can't even
somebody wrote the first thing dead ass
your honor
is that you're laughing at
dude you're not saying we bleed New York
dog right so like check this out judge
dead ass man
we gonna be doing a trial right and
that's that's all good that's that ain't
that you know not for nothing my man's
my man's in them he ain't do [__] all
right if you say he did that's cap
um
you know what I mean you're talking
about did he do it or did he do it do it
right so the difference is right
it's like crazy dog
shh after after the verdict comes in
guilty
I'll try hard your honor I don't know
what you're talking about
cap
uh
I mean dude
how do you say that to a judge
that's the funniest [__] thing
this is not true that's that's cap your
honor I wanna I have to listen to it
again I mean I will start by saying that
this assertion that
I did not mention the 403 argument don't
worry about that okay because it
wouldn't be it I'd have to how much is
The Lure 25 okay don't even worry about
that okay okay I understand that it's
just not true it's cap to be honest but
um
that aside though I mean I'm gonna lose
oh I
uh my mind this is imagine you're you're
on trial for murder what is it stealing
what is it I don't [__] know
and your lawyer says to the [__]
judge your judge that's cap
you go like this
25 to life
25 to Life you get red you start getting
ready you know what I mean he's like I
gotta put my stuff in I gotta
put my get my stuff in order see what's
going on here because I'm going 25 to
life
that's
did this make it would does this go
viral
how did this not go viral
somebody wrote you're bugging with these
charges your honor
dead ass
all right well that's absolutely insane
that is so [__] funny
I was just no I was thinking about the
guy who got that [__] Apple Tattoo
when I was doing that because I'm on
White Lotus
instead of uh whatever like I mean I can
I would do I get we got the thing right
we gotta change the thing Dominic Fike
got the Apple Tattoo on him
uh you got the Apple Tattoo on him the
logo
so if he had so he's a
he's on Euphoria and he they have to
cover it every time why would you get
the [__] Apple to a low any logo on
you is batshit crazy remember the the
basketball player that I had to got the
supreme logo and then Supreme suit him
and it's just it's a brand man this is
pretty cool I guess I need to get one
I gotta get you know what I gotta get
[__] uh
what's that arpo the dog Harpo what's
the dog food what's the dog food
Alpo I'm gonna get Alpo on my [__]
forehead
Alpo dude yo what up I'm gonna take
pictures like this
you know when I see a [__] guy take a
pic like this
I lose my [__] and also
is that the show like I feel like it
originated to show the [__] grills
dude it's evolved to the guys just do it
you're showing your gums dude hey you're
gross dude when you do this you're
showing it hey your dentist is supposed
to see that hey dude don't ever show me
inside your body
unless you're unless unless I'm a doctor
yeah
or like this one guys do like this
oh man people really out there think of
their models right people are really out
there just
do it I gotta start taking pictures like
this near my car like this
and then one like this
dude I'm at
if I unironically took a peek like that
or [__] God damn it dude I'm just
waiting for one of these comedians to
lose their minds and [__] do some
[__] like that and start thinking that
they're really real dude what's up with
starting a set so late with artists like
dude they're like yo eight o'clock but
also 11.
as you are no doubt aware
many Frank Ocean many Coachella
attendees were disappointed with Frank
Ocean's headline set last night which
started an hour late and featured
stretches of the performer just vibing
to pre-recorded tracks it's lazy knock
on reports that the festive Al and Tim Z
that
in the days before his performance ocean
suffered a serious ankle injury okay
understood
one of the changes involved mixing and
onstage ice rink capable you know don't
have that
100 La based hockey players have been
rehearsing on elevated ice rink at
Paramount Studios
they joined the set as background
dancers and were given
I mean a Prada bag
okay I don't
yeah dude I agree with this
I totally agree with this [__] there's
people that just
like critics pick dude critics are such
horseshit and they pick these people
that are just like this one comment
right here can the Untouchable critic
darling status go away now
I love Frank Ocean but it's been close
to 10 years since his last album first
of all I didn't know that it has
that's [__] dude
there's some people that just can't do
wrong it's crazy I I don't know one
Frank I know one Frank Ocean song
but man these [__] just get
anointed you know just anointed
like uh Timothy
Sport Chalet or whatever the [__] his
name is
we take you to the Limit
[Applause]
here's another all right let's do some
deserved skills
here's one on tick tock so you know it's
gonna be good
that's cap lawyer
holy [__] dude [__]
are you good dad
unclear oh my god dude did he say I'm
clear wow dude
we got to see that again
holy [__] dude
are you good
unclear oh unclear
oh [__]
died
yo that's [__] up thank God he had a
helmet on
oh my God
oh my God oh my God that was horrific
nobody deserves that honestly um that's
I mean
bowling
oh this is an [__] move
what a piece the bomb
that is an ultimate 10 plus deserve at
scale what a piece of [__] also with
that hair that everyone has you know
come on
what a piece of [__] [__] dude
honestly I could stand to have him get
hurt a little bit more even like the
[__] I love how the edge of the TV
went right in his skull thank God for
that okay and for him to Windmill a
bowling ball and the mom dude just had
it listen to that Nick
thank you
Nick just had it up to here boom [__]
yeah hell yeah the TV hit him with that
stupid bowling animation you know just
like a
a cloud coming out of the ball or some
[__]
turkey and then a turkey dude
deserved it I wish Karma was that quick
all the time
I wish it was that quick all the time
you know how much better the world would
be if Karma was legit that quick
[__] yeah
okay here's another dessert skill that's
a that was the best dessert skill we
ever had
that one
isn't showing her
um
here we go
sliding down
you like this one is that
what did he think was gonna
what language is that you know
oh [__] his [__] came out you know
just straight up his [__] came out ah
bad friends all these guys
oh these guys are dying
a made-up language okay so that's
I look like he got real hurt so eight oh
so otherwise it would be higher
I mean dude his whole [__] ass came
out
here we go
oh no
oh [__] oh [__] imagine that's your dad
see is it outside in place I just walked
right but I got hit twice in the head
that's how bad that was you got hit with
the ladder and the [__] ship
see now it's locked in place they just
walk right up
and then he drowned you know just
[__] just oh my God lights out for
that guy hey guy put the ladder on a
little more securely you know hey hey
Captain move the boat closer
was so far away
oh he's wearing overalls you know
God when things happen to guys overalls
it's always a little bit sweeter
holy [__] that's uh
I hope he didn't get hurt that's a nine
though
well that's it for YouTube if you want
the full episode the uncut the Raw
ish then go to patreon.com christalia
and you will get the entire episode and
also uh if you do that you can get all
of the backlogged episodes of
congratulations and there's like 26 of
them now that you could just go binge if
you're on a road trip or chill in they
also make good gifts it's just six bucks
uh patreon.com crystalia thanks guys
[Music]
thank you